the essential issue in this race do you
also think that the federal government
should have a role in social planning
and social activities you think that's
the central role of the federal
government the federal government
already does a lot in that area with
their regulations and their tax that
look at what I said about President
Obama and he's basically dictating
social policy and social engineering
through his grant programs we believe
that the values that are taught at home
around the kitchen table and in the
church synagogue temple or mosque should
be reinforced by the schools and not
undermined by the school you're not
gonna do well either in Iowa
or beyond if you're not pro marriage
pro-family and pro-life whether you're
coming from a libertarian perspective or
a more traditional conservative
perspective you should read my book no
way it'll let you know let you know
it'll lay out how the government can be
have policies are conducive to families
without obviously dictating to families
out of their structure
man up and be President what that means
I think mama had an out there and I
think I think it's selfish
[Applause]
[Music]